la troisième question c'était sur les
conditions tarifaires etc le contrat
européen alors
écoutez les les le contrat le contrat du
vaccin contre la covid est un contrat
qui sont CDI contrats qui sont discutés
au niveau de notre maison mère
directement avec la Commission
européenne au niveau de l'Europe
cette partie relève vraiment du secret
des affaires c'est c'est la récompense
c'est à dire c'est ça fait vraiment
partie des secrets des affaires alors au
niveau de la France et c'est ce que nous
contrôlons ici c'est au niveau de la
France nous avons travaillé mais dans la
main avec la tars force depuis le début
et nous en sommes toujours en discussion
et notamment par rapport au livraisons
et ça c'est la responsabilité ma
responsabilité et la responsabilité de
pfizer france